the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam told us
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you will have on your scale
[Music]
how are you guys doing many of you will
know that Ben shipiro is a panus a
dastardly panus who is known for his
Craven avoidance of debates throughout
the years due to unwillingness and
abject cowardice from his side he's a
vehement supporter of course of the
Zionist cause but he is also a coward
who has not debated on a fair footing
anybody who is on the opposing side in
fact prefers to go to
universities and have uneven settings
speaking to college students this is
very well known of him he's a well-known
coward now even I think his own people
will tell him that but having said that
and putting this man uh and his
cowardice to the side for a second he
has found the opportunity to come and
try and bech the good name of the Muslim
Community of the United Kingdom let's
take a look at what he has had to say
and come back and respond in kind the
open in a place called Rochdale in the
UK back in 2003 and that was because a
15-year-old girl died and when there was
an investigation into why she died it
turns out that she had been one of the
girls who was groomed by these gangs for
folks who don't know this story
basically over the course of literally
decades and there allegations of this
going all the way back to the 1970s
basically over the course of decades
white girls were prayed on by Muslim men
in gangs they were rape gangs they were
not grooming they treat them they call
them grooming gangs they weren't
grooming gangs they were rape gangs
because these are all underage girls who
are being traded around by now of course
Rochdale rotheram and Telford were very
significant in terms of the media
coverage and very tragic incidents and
it's true that those particular cases
were dominated by quote unquote Asian
gangs now that there is no denying that
but that was 13 years ago and where were
you Ben Shapiro when they were doing the
right to rape protest when that guy from
unit 100 m 100 raped the man on
videographic evidence and we saw
discussions even in the CET about the
right to rape and these guys are this
and these guys are that where was your
voice then where was your voice when
even the Times of Israel and other
outlets have
reported that people who are
pedophiles were coming back to Israel
using the right to return
legislation in order to avoid
prosecution in whatever country they
were in and this man who has not said a
word about what's happened with his own
Jewish friends or compatriots or
colleagues or co-religionists or
whatever term you want to use to
describe them who are part of one of the
most organized if not probably the most
organized rape if you want to call it
that way or grooming gang in all of
Central America
um in Guatemala which has only been
reported two weeks ago not a peep from
this pipsqueak not even one peep but as
soon
as as soon as Elon
Musk his slave Handler says a word
about uh rotheram or Rochdale maybe he
didn't know about it before something
that happened 13 years ago he's talking
about the Muslim population the bastard
this bastard this pipsqueak of a man
this insignificant man so the question
is why haven't you attached
Judaism to the actions of the criminals
in Guatemala why have you not attached
Judaism or jewishness to Jeffrey Epstein
the most prolific trafficker in the last
century why haven't you done that and
you have the audacity to come and speak
about an incident that took place 13
years ago and you will be informed if
you're following my content especially
if you follow the last video that I've
just done on Elon Musk that what's
happened in rdale and rotheram and tford
is not an indication of what has
happened in grooming gangs throughout
the United Kingdom with the latest
report of the CSA the child sex sexual
assault report it shows very clearly
that there is not a
disproportionality viav Asians or
pakistanis in fact they had a separate a
separate classification or
subcategorization for pakistanis there
isn't when you're thinking about it on a
nationwide scale of course what happened
13 years ago in those particular towns
are the exception to this
rule however it's not an argument to be
made now as he continued speaking Mr
Shapiro he kind of dug his own grave a
little bit more let's see what he has to
say next I mean this idea that you can
just tell the people to sit down and
shut up and ignore the fact that their
countries are being inte are being
overrun with people coming from places
that hate the country that really hate
the country and hate the
civilization people are only going to
take that for so long isn't that ironic
that the way he described that situation
where you have immigrants coming into a
country
not being friendly which I don't agree
with I do not believe that there is an
antithetical or diametrically opposed
relationship between Muslims and Western
people in the full sense even the most
conservative and staunch and if you want
to put it in your terms fundamentalist
whatever islamist whatever derogatory
term you want to use Muslims there is no
such evidence for that you'd have to
bring evidence that there's a
diametrical opposition there may be
tension but I don't think there is a
diametrical opposition
and I think there is a symbiotic
relationship between the two communities
and there is a mutual giving and taking
from the two communities David Cramer
himself said the Muslim Community in
Britain is the most
charitable is the most charitable
Community um we also have the fact that
obviously we got Muslims putting
billions of pounds into the economy
billions of Sterling Pounds into the
economy we have many other metrics which
we can measure the contribution that
that British Muslims or American Muslims
or Western Muslims in general have made
to their respective countries but that's
another conversation for another day
isn't it interesting Shapiro isn't it
interesting that the way you describe
the situation is actually quite similar
to what happened to Palestine because if
you know the history of Palestine you'll
know
that it started off with Jewish
immigration into Palestine and the way
you described how the far right feels
you would never offer the same kind of
concessionary or
charitable explanation to the
Palestinian cause or to the Palestinians
who were in the land and then all these
people came in fact you Aid those who
killed them so why is it that you have
one standard here and another standard
there I don't understand but what I
don't understand is when you're going to
summon the C courage to meet me on a
mutual platform and speak either face to
face or you can be in your little Studio
when your little
chair you can speak to the audience from
home you might as well just take the
beating quite frankly the intellectual
beating just take it it's better to get
into a discussion at this stage with me
and take your loss than for you to be a
coward and remain known as a coward for
the rest of of your
life hey you are you wasting your time
on social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a Masid a DA Center
establishing a Masid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even more